yellow and pink welcome to this video
yeah this is an entirely new format that
I'm excited about I try to do something
different here and what I've done in the
past is I have dipped those videos for
solving technical puzzles you know with
the various platforms so I used I think
just sort call my fuse to test temple
these kind of things now I want to do
something different and you see the
thing on the left hand side little game
strategy I want to do um positions that
are more of a strategic nature and want
to solve them um or try to solve them
and share my thoughts how I'm going to
do it I would also move the pieces
around a little bit what you normally
don't do but I think it makes it a
little bit more accessible so how do I
get those positions I'm not really a way
out of an online site where you can get
randomized strategically focused
position so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use a book I guess for the
first video I can maybe use others later
I use them
grandmaster preparation book positional
play by Grandmaster or guard these are
really difficult problems and they it
has 150 exercise positions and I use
those positions sometimes in my own my
own lessons but I used you still mostly
the first 20 to 30 so what I'm going to
do is now I'm going to basically get a
random number on my mobile and this will
then select what position I get so
between number 30 and number 150 and
then it will put it on and try to solve
it yeah Mina and I have to do it like
that otherwise it looks like I'm
cheating so 30 150 other see see that's
like maybe you don't
so I'm generating a number
now and it's 134 see that 134 so I'm
going to go to position 134 and put that
on and see what happens there those are
difficult so you can easily embarrass
yourself and 134 from the game then
really let go Moscow 2004 so let's set
up the position um let's see um it is
it's not a position that so like yeah
basically almost an opening position
yeah I'm sorry yeah this takes a bit of
time but otherwise it looks a bit
strange I have to do it with this random
otherwise sir it looks really weird so I
have this I think this is the position
like to play orientation back let me see
I don't want to put out the wrong
position and then completely I can
answer all of myself so this is is the
position of course I mean then we have
an engine here and II chest but of
course I'm not going to use that so
let's have a look we have a position
here that really looks like we've just
we have basically in the opening stages
probably it was some sort of noodles or
Catalan maybe bogo Indian thing it's
yeah Black has the Queen on h5 it's a
bit unusual and we have see a deep aunts
traded
like a knight on c6 that's also uncommon
now you oftentimes don't have the night
in front of the pawn um what is also
remarkable is the position of the White
Queen on d3 this is also somewhat
uncommon yeah not not so easy I'm like
supposed to have a good solution here it
does not mean by the way with those
exercises that the site we are looking
for is winning the game with it but just
find the correct way of continuing hmm
so what am I thinking about both sides
have not Castle which is also also
interesting the first move that springs
to mind is canceling long and opposing
rook on the aid against the Queen or d3
and something that comes to my mind that
also threatens Knight takes d4 on a
purely tactical base this is actually
already a little bit annoying because
there's also frf here so just show you
I'm thinking about long cancelling and
now I'm threatening to take on d4 I mean
I can do this in my mind I don't need to
move to this but I think it's it's
better because it should be some kind of
discussion of the position it's it's me
solving it but also trying to solve it
but also showing you what I'm thinking
about so long castles threatens to take
as the bishop is unprotected on g2 and
if white um decides to castle here e5
comes into consideration like castling
and then we five
the pin here this is something we're
looking at and both five in taken and
grab d5 long cathode looks like looks
normal let's say a natural candidate
move what could be a drawback of long
castles currently currently I don't
really see it it makes sense to uncheck
some some strategic points of this
position for example purposes good
pieces bad pieces one thing that really
is some kind of obvious is that if you
casts along the white queen is not well
placed on d3 the default pond is also
slightly weak due to this a knight on c6
and this M the spinning pinning business
when you cancel along here you're really
threatened to take on the form so what
is right going to do wrong cancels may
be a three Bishop takes pawn takes
something like this if he goes here that
could be an idea so that after capturing
the D pawn will take Knight takes d4
doesn't wait Knight takes d4
[Music]
and Knight takes d4 I think doesn't
quite work here here the queen is also
tagged and that doesn't work I think
take this this yes it might actually
work technically I don't think I want to
take this this looks weird on the other
hand and after a three you can also just
consider there should be seven and keep
everything intact so I mean I think that
also would work okay but let's not focus
on Locke castling exclusively it looks
completely completely normal I think the
main problem for whitey is rikishi porn
queen on d3 and unprotected g2 bishops
or long castles looks completely correct
is there something else we should try to
check out if the opponent has some sort
of threat that we're missing
[Music]
Queen on h5 maybe is there something I
don't I don't see any anything wait that
white can try if we cancel long auntie
castles short and we fight it's just
good right yeah it's just a good
position mean what is the draw is there
drawback too long castle it looks a
little bit simple and those exercises
usually add them difficult not all of
them but most of them are it says
something else that I'm missing it says
something better maybe yeah well don't
don't we see it to be honest I mean you
can theoretically speaking try other
completely different approaches in this
position but they don't look logical
really yeah they're not good things like
let's say Bishop takes you three while
we captures Queen f5 trying to yeah just
just to show what I'm saying here do
this kind of thing can be interesting
there is an opening line that has
exactly this idea so that after
capturing like an try to clamp down on
those squares if you actually have time
with black to sort your pieces then this
could work with here this looks like it
looks awful cannot take I mean this
waiver you can claim it takes takes nine
h4
and this is also a volume to take on c3
looks wrong in this position I wonder if
there is some other IDN to exploit the
long diagonal and this is this spinning
situation but then I don't quite see it
you can you know what you can think of
is h5 this is this is definitely
something to check
hmm five immediately 90 85 90 85 as in
clueless could be 5
ie five looks fishing looks very fishy
so I would probably just cancel long
what is what is the big deal with that
room so let's check the dust white
threaten anything I don't see it
what about weaknesses does black have
weaknesses
c6 v 7s is also vulnerable but there is
simply no move I mean the knight would
have to move but it cannot do that after
castling long a move net no I was just
thinking Queen a 5-4 Bishop a6 so it is
that that's ridiculous really
I'm just trying to see if I miss any
other candidate move that is the
relevant here I don't see it I think a
e5 I was thinking like this might work
this and this I don't I don't think it
works on a king move b7 eggs
I don't think b7 is always hanging and
here that cannot be great for black
before all tanks for me is random so he
5 doesn't seem to work and what else is
now
I mean if we ignore long castles this
model is also something that
strategically speaking I would find okay
because I mean this increases this
control and in some cases you can take
on c3 put put piece on the light squares
but compared to long necklaces so
clearly name so what is the deal is
there a move that I'm missing is that
this is really a bit curious if I this
the thread maybe maybe you want yeah
maybe this a3 effect Liam that this is
critical
nanite chicks I think it works
I mean this well you say this is between
and this one ring that's screen a six in
some cases now it's still a pretty
strange line don't think it should it
should work for it
like you take take take now create six
less should be seven so I can try to
track this but it would be very weird
random between a six is a threat
it's not like it's completely ridiculous
but I can also go back I mean just this
should still work a castle to e5 there
may be d5 now and at this possible you
know at least if or is at least working
I mean it feels to me like I'm somehow
to superficially and I don't quite get
it
five is very substantial maybe um maybe
wide can to clean the somehow out of the
default I can still take can still take
him yeah this is Fork
believe it I would castlelong him yeah
so I think I'm going to check the
solution pendants it down
it doesn't feel like somehow doesn't
feel like I've got again in some way but
then you cannot sit there for for half
an hour
I'm curious what the what the solution
is that is just long cancel so I'm I was
correct down long castles yeah so that
was actually not that difficult in non
carefully looking at the weakness and
yeah so careful Sami has also played
short castles was reply night be five is
a move mentioned here in the notes to
hang on to the porn it's not a move that
is so maybe it's not a move that you
necessarily have to see a six is given
here night a 797b 696 and again D five
years and plug is using a superior
development and after Castle 35 years
and time that was also my main line
thinking that this should work after he
five when really playbook AC one and
click or took it so this is what is in
the book
however it's oftentimes interesting to
check what the computer says so
let's switch it on it gives long castles
that's the best move okay and then it
gives black already a good advantage the
move a3 was something that I wasn't
totally sure about I was thinking I
might even be able to return but the
computer wants to take yeah this wasn't
totally clear so TX you had a computer
and have a look at the computer actually
thinks that this is okay for what I I
had a really bad feeling about this and
it is in fact good for white in some way
understand so I was my hunch wasn't bad
there I was also thinking I might be
able to just retreat castles 5d five or
four as one of the computer lines okay
here I thought okay I should be okay
which is true there is something better
though yeah sometimes if you have an
idea like long castle and you're not
totally sure about the online sometimes
to just be sure that you are okay with
something simple it's really helpful
like here um okay taking is of course
the other principle ooh and then play e5
yeah indeed that doesn't look bad like
this and he fired immediately there's
still this threat of capturing twice M
you know okay so they was compared to
what sometimes you see in those books
pretty pretty okay I did not did not
make a complete fool of myself
I think let me just
put the them and I think I'm going to do
a second one that was interesting
let's do a second one going to generate
a new number it's 118 yeah
118 whether it might happen that I know
the hot position and then of course I
will doing the dice roll
118 so call of mommy Gianna also a
position that feels like only shortly
after the opening and we look for black
again yeah I'm not really quick with the
board setup but I'm happy if I'm not
making a mistake so this this this K
Lucas here here here next there and
blink to play this is correct
and look squared so intuition black okay
so and you know free I didn't see
anything
yes okay so look to claim
yeah it's correct and he had the engine
I mean it showed some kind of advantage
to effect it also indicates that it was
kind of it is the right positioning in
stride position
okay so a black to play interesting
black M in this position could just take
on f3 I mean just grab the pair of
bishops did I mention it also cool off
against on vidyard off weena needle 2008
I think that is a rapid tournament
without a ladle and so black could just
take f3 and be reasonably happy with the
pair of bishops after Queen takes yeah
like this is the super simple thing and
maybe 7s hanging
yep I don't know
I don't want to play c6 here I think
that that that looks good we get a spawn
my droopy aids also not super
comfortable okay 90 x f3 should not be a
terrible move it just not clear that
this anywhere near the best move I can
tell you what I thought right away I
mean just my first instinct is to check
out c5 attack this night and you can now
pretty easily calculate some lines and
then the night must move there is no
counter attacking now that that one can
do this you can I think really louder so
quite cannot go to e2 so night c2 on I'd
be five are the moves that should be
check yeah and now if you go to c2 which
is probably not the critical one but
let's say you do it then you take Bishop
temple yeah now 95 95 90 XD film Knight
takes d5 Bishop g7 Knight takes c3 okay
this is not working it is this is this
or maybe also some other discoveries so
green moves I don't know where d1 and
then by five what's my Ozma thinking
even though you can can debate if there
is something better
Knight takes Knight takes
and maybe this tumor is better for black
hair I mean that is better for black I
could assemble this this this maybe here
you can actually do something else I
mean this is definitely and better for
black it's a strong Bishop against
pretty bad noise
this is this looks more critical at
first glance but now that I look at it
maybe it's actually not more critical
again you take clean takes and now you
the immediate d5 is interesting with ok
let's go here and where is the Queen
going
we have 94 so I'm going back here I have
this one that's that's good for like c5
looks like for me and pretty obvious
solution to this
you just get this it has a very natural
flow to it
but okay it's just like my initial idea
and that that would that I would play in
a blitz blitz game let's say but what
let's try to learn to do to grasp this
position a little bit better not just
like see a move make a move often
actually the first thought is correct
and I have this hunch that at the end it
will be c5 anywhere let's have a look b7
is a check so it's something to get
ignored on I cannot just play like any
mood yeah I can play would be a Tonya or
c6 or something definitely not and one
actually a fun and I'm missing something
here
and they're not that many candles is the
thing d7 is attacked so not playing
Queen c8 on the eight or something when
I see a dynamic possibility like c5 it's
a good and bad pieces here this is
definitely a good piece that we will
take our night only five is of course
not bad but good see if as Bishop c6 all
the Sun transits Bishop into a great
piece
so this and we had it at me sort this a
little bit probably most critical is
this one I just wonder here if this
maybe even something better I thinking I
definitely have to take is this other
Queen moves we can think about the
selenium but I thought 94 is good like
this is this
so it's also still a checked now yeah
yeah I'm just clearly better doesn't it
can never work this is dispatch
this is also interesting in 97,000 I
teach five thank you it's not a good
idea it's also something to think about
after Queen you want if this is an
option the knight cannot take pawn take
1996 I am it just doesn't work I'm sorry
I think just c5 it is just c5 okay no it
justifies would be weird if not let's
check it yay c5 yeah it is a
supernatural continuation
c5 I missed something hey interesting
light c2 is the main line in the book or
what sorry what was played actually
because here I missed something yeah
that's nice actually
so this is this Queen d1 but here I was
thinking a 94 with a 6 strong because
here the light is trapped didn't see
this so this means that 92 is actually
mandatory and and then you just take a
trip c6
what did I have did I continue the slide
95 and 95 didn't work and Queen to itto
D 594 is also good yeah so I got this
one right let's just check it a little
bit with the engine and see if the
engine agrees with everything you see 5
is a stronger spoke and now we are 95 I
didn't see the a6 resource even though I
think I just want to check here I was
thinking like if form or d5 is also good
or the 5 is strong ok or 94 K so it
wasn't entirely stupid um even though a6
is a good move to see them so okay so 92
chips chips chips
okay 95 kg didn't work and clean you
water that actually is the main
knowledge from the game d5 design
95 isn't actually given yeah maybe night
a 94 is stronger and all that there to
get it this is the rain this is I'm a
bit surprised that the engine sets as
equal because this position is not equal
I mean black is okay it gives like a
slight edge of these black should be a
bit better here because the night is not
well placed on the c2 and I have a non
symmetrical conformation which should
benefit the bishop so it is definitely a
producer where I would always take to
take black but it's not to that much
here 94 stronger yeah for sure for sure
yes ok I've done two positions I hope
you like the form it's interesting I
think discussing a couple of more
strategically minded position even
though those were relatively concrete
sometimes the positions are far less ya
dependent on agreed to concrete moves on
these times it was more more like that
yeah I hope you enjoyed it and if you do
give me some comments
and I'll do this again it's also
interesting for me because well I'm
solving those exercises and it's good
training for me thanks for watching my
life